[Music]
hi I'm Jimmy this is Billy I was out
last week because this guy had a hard
surgery but look he's fine everybody
Jimmy Kimmel returned to his late night
show on Monday alongside his adorable 7
month-old son Billy
the comedian took last week off to be
with his family as Billy underwent heart
surgery Billy's doing great by the way
he has one more surgery Kimmel was
emotional during his monologue he
thanked Chris Pratt Tracee Ellis Ross
Melissa McCarthy and Neil Patrick Harris
for filling in as host they each gave a
full day of their very busy lives to
give me time off and I'm grateful to
them for doing that and daddy cries on
TV but Billy doesn't all jokes aside
Kimmel made a passionate plea to defend
children's rights to healthcare
specifically encouraging viewers to call
their congregational representatives to
renew chip the children's health
insurance plan I don't know what could
be more disgusting than putting a tax
cut that mostly goes to rich people
ahead of the lives of children
[Music]